sonido el correcto
francés voltaire en el mes de febrero
como cada año canadá celebra el mes de
la historia de los negros aquí en el
país cuál es su reflexión a propósito de
este mes
de hecho hace 30 años empezó
esencialmente en quebec a organizar un
mes no es solamente de festejo es un mes
de reflexión es un mes donde se aborda
el problema los problemas que tienen las
comunidades afro canadiense que son de
origen diferente
y
el mes de febrero es el momento en que
todo tipo los organismos los individuos
participan a la vez en actividades de
reconocimiento de personalidades que han
aportado
a la cultura afro canadiense pero
también la cultura canadiense
globalmente que sean músicos que sean
empresarios que sean escritores de
novelista poeta pero también
y gentes que están involucrados en la
organización de los sectores más
pobre de las comunidades y es el mes en
que hay actividades en toda la ciudad no
solamente en montreal pero también en
una mesa que coordina que coordina las
actividades que beck entonces son las
dos partes donde hay casi 90% de las
actividades porque esta población está
repartida esencialmente entre montreal
de la región de gatineau y quebec
ahora france cuando se habla de la
comunidad negra indudablemente hay que
tocar el tema del racismo y al respecto
quería preguntarle usted cree que
existen expresiones o que hay racismo no
de parte de sectores muy específicos
sino en el conjunto de la sociedad tanto
en quebec como en canadá en general
existe una postura racista hacia la
comunidad negra aquí no hay que recordar
que en 1980 la corte suprema de canadá y
las comisiones de derecho desde 1980
reconocen la existencia de lo que se
llama el racismo
sistémico es decir prácticas
discriminatorias
que están enraizados en una serie de
instituciones públicas principalmente en
la policía y uno ve que todos los
informes
los estudios que se han hecho acerca del
hostigamiento acerca de
en el sistema de justicia número de
condena condena mucho más fuerte y un 9
recientemente y esto es una paradoja que
en el mes de la historia negra jugó este
esta confrontación esta cosa que fue
arrestado un profesor de la universidad
de montreal que los seis días en la
cárcel por un crimen que no ha cometido
y uno se puede preguntar se puede
preguntar dos cosas primero primero
hubo un testigo porque no lo entendieron
y es porque es un latino pues porque
bueno la policía no tomó en cuenta
donde la palabra de un testigo ocular
segunda cosa si no fuera uno puede
preguntarse la existía de una cámara del
ministerio de transporte de la regina
transport que es que nos revela lo que
ha pasado
este tipo hubiera sido parte de un error
judicial porque no es solamente la
policía pero la dsp y es decir también
es a partir de la vídeo que empezaron a
cambiar de postura para decir que cámara
no tenía nada que ver en esto aunque
algo tiene al perfil de un delincuente
es un es un doctor antes es un tipo que
lo ve el físico no tiene el físico
y no tiene ningún antecedente judicial
segunda cosa es que uno puede
preguntarse si la policía porque fue un
policía atacado y lo peor para un
policía que le quitaron su arma
acaso reaccionaron emocionalmente y no
profesional profesionalmente pero no se
preguntan hoy día en el periódico
alguien preguntaba si él se hubiera
llamado
camarón en lugar de cámara hubiera sido
blanco hubiera actuado de esta misma
manera entonces este es uno de los
múltiples casos
donde se habla de afilar espacial de un
hostigamiento que si fuera un joven que
tuve antecedentes uno no sabe que lo que
hubiera pasado entonces uno puede hay
discriminaciones también hubo un chileno
ruiz sonido creo que fue la que fue a
corte y ganó
porque por un poema de acento porque
tengo un acento
español un poco más marcado y hay casos
yo creo que está la raisa ni historia
uno olvida que mcdonald que fue una pata
de fundadora de canadá su política era
keep canal a white mantengamos canadá
blanco y también era muy anti francófono
uno ve lo que pasó con en manitoba donde
en menos de una semana el líder mestizo
y lo condenaron a muerte y entonces uno
se prevé en ti
y esta política fue presente hasta los
años 50 cuando se cambió la ley de
inmigración y entonces uno se dice si
hay un racismo sistémico hay necesidad
de debate público hay necesidad hoy día
el frente a problemas yo diría globales
a las que estamos confrontados los
cambios climáticos problemas de pandemia
sabe
ahora estamos viviendo en un planeta y
que todos pertenecemos a la misma
especie pero y que el destino será común
o va a ser problemático
ahora como decíamos al comienzo de la
entrevista cada año se sucede la
recordación del mes de la comunidad
negra en canadá también en
periódicamente se suceden las
declaraciones de las autoridades
diciendo que hay que combatir el racismo
sistémico al cual usted hace referencia
y más allá de estas declaraciones se han
logrado avances que es lo que falta ser
que en todo caso en su opinión cuál es
la mejor manera de combatir actualmente
este racismo sistémico bueno primero yo
hace 22 años
organizamos todos los en los meses de
febrero de marzo la semana de acción
contra racismo yo soy el que presido al
órgano no es un organismo es un programa
de nuestro centro
yo diría educación pero educación no es
suficiente porque hay un instrumentos
legales
que están en así que están en las las
cartas de los derechos la sal de duab
prohíbe todo tipo de formas de
discriminación pero sabemos que no se
cambian las sociedades por decretos
entonces hay una necesidad de educación
hay necesidad de de no negar la
existencia de fenómenos como racismo
sino de abrir debates públicos sobre
este fenómeno pues es la manera a mi
entender de que se pueda avanzar porque
hasta ahora si yo
en mi biografía personal
y quebec en 1958 yo tenía 10 años yo
vine con mis padres desde eeuu a quebec
después estuve aquí en 1967 durante la
exposición universal y yo vi algunos
cambios la sociedad que me cuadró con la
revolución tranquila se estaba abriendo
al mundo
yo volví de chile 73 aquí y después al
80 entonces he visto algunos cambios en
la sociedad por lo menos en lo creado
montreal ha cambiado radicalmente
yo diría los 50 últimos años y creo que
esto es una paradoja
y yo diría una inquietud en ciertos
sectores de la población que de
cualquier no vive el cambio
como dice el romano está más en roma o
mostrando está más el quebec es
diferente es diferente porque tu hábito
por ejemplo cuando yo llegué a 73 había
12 argentinos algunos chilenos que
vinieron con el golpe de estado en chile
algunos mexicanos que vinieron con los
mariachis 23 cubanos individuales o un
dominicano médico así había algunos
individuos
hoy día hay comunidades latinas hay
comunidades árabe hay comunidades
haitianas
había 4.000 haitianos a los años 70 hoy
día hay casi 200.000 haitianos
de origen haitiano entonces esta
sociedad está cambiando y creo que lo
mismo que uno ve en países como europa
como francia hay un debate sobre cómo
que la sociedad se va a cambiar mientras
que la sociedad siempre se haga es decir
francesa que llegaron aquí y terminaron
siendo canadiense franceses
cuando llegaron los ingleses porque
antes eran canarias se denominaron
canadienses son canadienses francesas
cuando llegan los ingleses que tampoco
eran ingleses porque vinieron mal la
mayoría de eeuu así que eran día
aclimatados yo diría en abril y después
se definieron como quebec o para
distinguirse de los otros canadiense
francés entonces son cambios que se
están dando y es normal todo sociedad
evoluciona y se transforma por la
demografía por
y la gente claro
cuando llegaron eran argentinos eran
haitianos y eran afroamericanos pero
cuál va a ser la denominación de sus
nietos o de su si se quedan en este país
si no se van de vuelta
esta sociedad está acá entonces a estas
resistencias
de grupos 19 en artículos de pensadores
que por ejemplo todo este debate sobre
el multiculturalismo y al miedo aquí
aunque nadie pretende asimilar a nadie
en las comunidades
pero la gente olvida que a partir de un
número a partir de un cierto vale a
partir de un cierto nivel demográfico
claro hay afirmación identidad y áspero
y esto es normal
y esto con la pandemia avalar otro
problema por ejemplo se está dando que
muchos
y canadiense franceses que se van
moviendo hacia
el campus uaz ya pequeña ciudad cercano
demostrándose montreal se va a reafirmar
que montreal es una sociedad cosmopolita
y
y esto es para durar igual que toronto
si dijeran que nadie piensa que esto tú
lo puede cambiar es la grande ciudad es
por naturaleza son cosmopolitas que sean
buenos aires que sean
parís hoy digan que sea nueva york son
sociedad son ciudad de cosmopoética
precisamente y no solamente aquí en
quebec en canadá sino también en otras
partes actualmente hay un movimiento que
dice que esa diversidad que se ve día a
día en la sociedad también debe
reflejarse en las posibilidades que se
dan en cargos altos o directivos en
empresas e instituciones en medios de
comunicación y existe un movimiento que
tiende a que esas organizaciones
reflejen la diversidad y cuando uno mira
a las instituciones en canadá en general
y en quebec en particular usted cree que
la diversidad social está
suficientemente reflejada o falta aún
avanzar en ese sentido también
totalmente no yo diría no y es necesario
que se vean estas y que esta sociedad
refleja la diversidad de jaime es muy
difícil yo diría que esa diversidad
aparezca
medios privados
porque hay que convencer la gente hay
que explicarlo pero el estado tiene esta
capacidad de nombrar en los consejos
administrativos de las grandes
instituciones públicas competencias que
si existan que vienen de américa latina'
de las comunidades afro canadiense de
mujeres para que reflejan la diversidad
real de esta sociedad
entonces yo hace años atrás yo escuché a
alguien decir hablaba en esta época de
minoría visible para hablar de estas
comunidades a foro y de y él decía claro
somos visible en la calle pero en las
instituciones somos invisibles
entonces hay una necesidad porque el
estado mismo fijó un cierto porcentaje
de gente que tenía que integrar
principalmente a una ciudad como moteado
de una ciudad muy diversificada para
integrar a la gente hay una resistencia
todavía
por ejemplo la policía su primer el
primer policía afro canadiense fue en
y hoy día hay un poco más de diversidad
latinos algunos asiáticos haitianos
africanos pero es un trabajo
de larga duración que implica a veces
maneras voluntarias que el estado decida
nombrar
gente en los consejos administrativos yo
me acuerdo cuando yo integré el consejo
de arte demostrado en aquella época
gramos
dos personas
de la diversidad yo que venía de
comunidad afro canadiense haitiano y la
otra que era una latinoamericana pero
esto implica otra manera
a abordar los problemas porque
efectivamente la gente no trataba
demandas que venían de estas comunidades
por qué
no lo consideraban
sobre de la misma manera que los otros
organismos culturales hoy día hay en la
comunidad latinoamericanas
enormemente de gente talentosa yo
publiqué con latín arte hace dos años
atrás un libro sobre los artistas
latinoamericanos de quebec
anteriormente de un chileno juan carlos
aguirre había publicado también un libro
sobre los artistas de las comunidades
migrantes y era una seguida entrevista
que era había ido bien era profesor en
el jefe del entonces uno ve que hay una
serie de talento
y no es de reconocer turno uno piensa
por ejemplo actualmente el nuevo
director de la orquesta de montreal
viene de venezuela
y es parte de un programa que se llamó
el sistema que fue a ir a iniciar
jóvenes en las varias pobre a la música
clásica y no es solamente el por qué
aparece en francia también la primera
mujer
afrovenezolana que va a dirigir una
orquesta sinfónica en francia donde uno
ve que el pueblo no es que no hay
talento porque el argumento de que no
están calificarla es falso si los
latinoamericanos o los haitianos o los
africanos o los magrebí nos quedan aquí
tienen a veces mucho más calificación
que
la población en general
por último francisco y brevemente hay
quienes sostienen que el mes de la
comunidad negra en montreal en quebec en
canadá no está mal pero que sería mejor
que el reconocimiento al aporte de esa
comunidad se llevará a cabo día a día
que respondería usted a esta yo creo que
es lo que tú dices es importante es
importante pero al mismo tiempo es un
poco la gallina de los huevos es decir
hay un mes ahora de la comunidad latina
organizado yo creo que hacer mes de
octubre de septiembre que se organiza el
mes de reconocimiento de las comunidades
africanas entonces la gente que han
migrado aquí su descendiente porque a
veces las migraciones van más allá de un
mes ni de un año hay gente que es tan
enraizado aquí desde más de 40 50 años
entonces es necesario es necesario
y celebrar este mes porque esperamos
todos que en algún momento no hay que
celebrar ningún mes porque sumó toda
parte de la misma comunidad humana pero
al mismo tiempo que lo que es necesario
que las universidades abran en centros
de estudios latinoamericanos que abran
centros de estudios africanos centro
estudio del caribe porque es una cosa
increíble hay un millón de gente en
quebec solamente que van a cuba
república dominicana pero que como dice
podrían preocuparse unos a un poco más
de estos país entonces hay una parte de
la universidad de abrirse y esto es
importante que y es una limpieza es una
limpieza porque la gente aporta idiomas
a veces aporta cultura aporta otra cosa
en la cultura culinaria en
es un enriquecimiento la de las
comunidades el otro día tuvo una
entrevista en el cual le dije a la
adecuada luego
eligió la la protección de al francés va
a pasar en la coordinación con lo que
están pasando con los países africanos
el destino el futuro del español está en
américa latina no en españa el futuro
del portugués está en brasil en
mozambique angola en cabo verde y no
necesariamente en portugal es decir hoy
día hay que tratar de ver qué es una
riqueza la diversidad
tras volver una vez más muchas gracias
por esta entrevista con radio canadá
internacional
muchas gracias guys